rafi was an interpreter for uk forces
in afghanistan who came here 10 years
ago
he told me his life is still in danger
and a new government scheme to allow
more afghan interpreters to move here
can't come soon enough currently most of
the interpreters or the alices who have
worked with the british forces or the
americans
are living in hidings they are moving
their homes
some of them are not living in their
their villages and cities where they are
born and
you know have lived the entire their
life and how real is the risk to those
people
did the past one year at least five
interpreters have been killed
both from the british and the americans
you tell him he can carry on
if he just pushes pushes the bike
through the junction
and then you can carry on yeah this one
yeah you can carry on just push the bike
through
the risk to local interpreters from
taliban reprisals
is expected to increase when
international troops complete their
withdrawal from afghanistan
later this year
more than 1400 interpreters and family
members have already settled here
the government says its newly announced
relocation scheme
could bring another 3 000. with the
western powers leaving
afghanistan the threat is increasing and
has increased
with targeted attacks against afghans by
the taliban so we think it's the right
thing to do to stand by these people
they they sacrificed a lot to look after
us and now we're going to do the same
rafi welcomes that sentiment but warns
people will still be left behind
if the uk decides who is and is not
at risk how many will qualify for the
current
newly announced scheme only time will
tell us
but i'm sure that there will be a number
of interpreters left behind
if we do not take the right measures now
to save their lives
the government says it is fulfilling its
moral obligation
and that no one who supported the uk's
armed forces in afghanistan should see
their life
put at risk gerard sky news